we did have some comedians who we sent
the stand-up act to including the great
David Spade who's kind enough to join us
David good morning thanks for joining us
hello Dan hello gosh what a night
my Memorial Day weekend I got to watch
that clip Fred C it would be easy to
crap all over this but I'm gonna try to
go through a little bit with you
first of all I like the Wardrobe you
didn't go Seinfeld suit you kept it very
casual sort of the untuck it look from
bachelor in paradise which I think a lot
of people liked I mean I think that's
very common okay you still there yeah no
points off their section rose feet hmm
it was an interesting bit because I sort
of thought it was a setup that might
need to be brought home it fizzled out a
little bit I will say you sort of
delivered it with confidence God knows
why but if you you push through it and
you might want to um you know maybe
start just some throw away topical thing
like hey did you see me climb those
apartments and save that baby you know
maybe something like that and then
people go oh you're not athletic you
wouldn't have done that year your next
bit was your mom gives you the
thermometer up your behind which again
that's not a bad area I I don't hate
that joke I think you said she did it
till high school which is funny I would
even say something more recently like
Memorial Day or something where it's
it's it's really recent you know like
where you say to high school and then a
side note I graduated high school two
weeks ago anything is sort of but I
didn't hate that one you you were you
were talking a little fast but that was
understandable given the silence and I
think that you had good stage presence
you you sort of plowed through it I
sometimes I'm on Ellen and if something
doesn't work I speed it up a little bit
which is a mistake but it happens it's
just a nervous thing I I thought overall
you sort of looked like you knew what
you were doing up there which is a
positive
maybe the material could be stronger but
at least you sort of buzz through it and
I only got the 331 okay then you missed
the last four minutes of it well I wish
I saw the closer because I'm right there
with you and I was at Caroline's that
night I tried to pause I couldn't yeah
you you guys have to cuz it's work but
this is sort of a freebie so I I felt I
think it was okay and and then the
bachelor was on and stuff but I thought
overall I don't you know I'm not giving
up I mean you're not going to Hollywood
but moment but but David this is at
Caroline's is it too big of a stage for
it was it too soon to go to Caroline's
just a second time he's ever done this
oh okay I didn't know how long he's done
it the second time
Caroline's is tough I mean it's
intimidating um it would be better to do
some dumpy little open mike nights at
pizzerias and sort of get used to the
tidal wave of silence because it can
throw you like a horse that gets spooked
if you get silence you don't really know
what to do and then your mind thinks of
that and not your next joke so I would
say that was sort of big because you're
known maybe they let you go on up there
but that's I'm sure you had some
disgruntled community to the back okay
but this is if we got good content yeah
like if I had a group a guy like if I
got you and Sandler and you know Jeff
Ross and maybe you know Chris Rock I
mean I gotta pay you but you know could
we cobble together like seven minutes of
some stuff for fritzy
I think I think so I think he can
deliver it and I think he he does look
like he knows he's doing so I'm not
gonna say it was all a big bomb but the
crowd almost was unfairly crickets I
mean I well I didn't tell unless they
give me the germ about Megan Markel and
they were not having it and it was Ellen
looked at me like it's a real like what
just happened I go Jesus the floor just
came out and at the commercial I go
Ellen I've never hit a wall like that on
a talked to she was I've never seen
someone hit a wall that are don't talk
[ __ ] maybe it was to shout at criticized
Megan Markel Damon oh yeah it was a day
of the wedding yeah but I go she's not
lady died just yet I mean give her a few
seconds I mean we can still make fun of
her for like five minutes but they
weren't having it and I had to get to
the rest of the bit because I had to get
to the next one so it was like that was
really trudging through the mud here's
another thing though Ritchie didn't say
hello to the audience when he got up on
stage that's like a nervous thing yeah I
think he just got up the one hi dogs are
funny I guess we're starting a mic stand
either he was told that you know you got
to say hello to the audience and you
have to move the mic stand out of the
way because there's a little bit of a
barrier there between you and the
audience right I mean we could still see
him obviously but I would say if he gets
on then yeah a little bit of a
settlement so they can take you in you
know just to get a quick feel for you so
hello and move the mic and even that BS
how you doing anything like that
actually just sort of relaxes them like
here we go
but you came at it probably because you
had a short amount of time and that's
some guys do that they don't waste any
time but it backfires a little bit
because I don't know why the audience
feels a little offended it's a bit
abrupt all right here's another clip for
you to break down here and seaton going
ahead and you know what I couldn't I
couldn't hear the last one so tell us
someone on the squad there that Apple
you know that was this the first one
where he had the observational humor
where he the opening one
right but it blanked out I'm like oh
it's okay let me hear that no you're
better yeah yeah you're better not
hearing it here you go
did we have one scene my mother is just
a neurotic crazy but she's so lovely
wonderful beautiful person should give
you the shirt right off her back off you
won't do that anytime soon she's not
exactly the most fit person well sir if
we don't need to see her with her with
her shirt off but basically growing up
we had a coffin to our pillow because if
she heard any of us my brother my sister
i coughing she'd sent us right to a lab
for one of those throat cultures to see
if you have strep throat so she was a
little a little crazy with that I didn't
find out till recently from a friend of
mine that if your mom is still taking
your temperature rectally when you're in
high school it's a time where that's
acceptable
okay so that's the that's the rectal
thermometer there with his mom and he
said that his mom would give you very
generous she'd give you the shirt off
her back but nobody wants to see that
yeah I couldn't hear it again but I sort
of I remember that joke thank God and uh
okay it was you know III I get it you
know he's not at the Madison Square
Garden so no one expects miracles but
these are at least in the vicinity of
jokes and I think with some tweaking and
you get a few people in there you should
try to load him up with a few comedians
not me of course but like you know get
Chris Rock and get those guys in runs a
week and get all the biggies and then I
think with the right stuff he could I
was a little shocked even in section row
seat
just a few polite you know chuckles and
they really they really hit her not him
in that I've had that you're like am i
saying that's right because there's
something there isn't there people but
they were like tapping out early on you
David thank you for spending a good
portion of your Memorial Day weekend to
critique Fritzi so that was very awesome
I appreciate the feedback there
Bret see I think overall it was fine and
you've got some potential and come back
next year and we're going to do this
again and I think it will come along a
little bit and I just stared at the
ceiling last night thinking of what I
would say all night
I'm glad we got through this and thanks
guys it's always good to talk to you
thank you David that's a David Spade
very kind David Spade critiquing David's
helping him out a little bit giving some
some advice for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]